So let's look at what lock synchronization looks like.
So we said that a lock, or mutex is
just a location in memory. So let's say that
we are using integers, to represent the lock structure. So
really, a lock is just a number. We initialize
a lock variable. So you pass a lock variable to
initialize to let's say a lock_init function. And what
it's going to do is set the lock. To an
unlocked value, which, let's say that's 0. So pretty
much lock initialization is just write 0, to that
memory location that represents the lock. Zero means unlocked
in this case. And now the lock function, the function
that tries to acquire the lock and make sure
that we're alone in doing that. We'll do something
like this. It will spin, as long as the
lock var is 1, which is the lock value and
once it sees that lock var is 0 not 1,
it's going to put 1 in that value, to mark
it as locked, and then we can enter the critical
section because others will now see our 1 and spin
there, and then to unlock, we will just, set the
lock variable back to being free, once we do this.
Coherence insures that whatever is waiting here, now sees a
0 and acquires the log themselves, so we let them
go, into the critical section. But this log function
doesn't really work. Suppose you have two threads, the
purple, and the green that come to this point
at the same time. The log was initialized to
0, both of them read the log for the first time, see 0. Both of them exit this
loop because the lock var is not 1, so
both of them come here, write 1 to the lock
var, and then leave this lock function, and now both
of them are in the critical section, which is what we
were trying to prevent. What we really need to correctly implement
the lock function, is that the looking at lock var and
seeing 0. And the writing to Lock var of 1, needs
to be atomic, which means we really need to do this
in a critical section of its own to make sure that
when we see a 0, we end up writing 1 before
anybody else gets to see a 0. Or at least, when we see a 0 we try to write 1,
but we know if we were the one to write
1 or if somebody did it before us. We should not
write 1 if somebody succeeded in writing 1 before us.
So we have some sort of a paradox here, in
that, we need locks here, in order to implement the
lock function. So how do we ever support a lock function?
Because in order to have a working lock function we
really need to have a lock and an unlock here.